so i see um a uh post a headline that
gwyneth paltrow was selling candles that
smelled like her vagina right and then
um
i was and i was like well who's the male
equivalent to that and uh
who would like to like ball scented
candles so i was like oh you know as i
posted the thing and then i just was
like and i never tagged the people but i
tagged the rock and i was like hey your
move man like [ __ ] they're going to
sell those like you know equality like
you you got to sell the ball get on that
hit up yankee doodle candle company
whatever and so i started getting all
these messages being like how do you
know the rock and i was like oh
everybody knows rock and then i look at
the post and he had commented on it like
brother i've been trying to get
you know uh boston kills going but i
keep burning my dick on the wax or
something like and then something else
and then he just made a joke and then
and then i got the audition for vince
mcmahon and and i was like i don't know
if this came from you but you know
thanks man show looks dope